before
i went in with knoxville and tremaine we
had done a lot of pitches and always got
kind of pushed aside and nothing went
through yeah okay yeah sure we'll call
you uh-huh sure whatever
well we went in with knoxville and
tremaine now knoxville goes in
and he's got a bunch of wicks attached
to big old
huge things of duct tape but the wicks
are like it's a live wick that he was
lighting on fire so he walks into mtv
lighting wicks fire in the hall long
wicks so we're like you know
20 seconds long and he's throwing these
uh these wicks they just go into
duct tape and he's throwing them and
everybody i mean these poor interns and
people
everyone's dropping their phones
computers are flying off desks people
are diving
they're thinking that knoxville being
knoxville is actually dropping like
you know these huge things of cherry
bombs everywhere it's going to explode
and then the whole office is diving on
the floor and he's laughing nothing goes
off because it's just wicks attached to
nothing
so we go in there everyone's kind of
already a little uneasy but everyone
knows that you know knoxville's in there
pitched another show with jeff germain
we go in and you know i've done some
fairly good pitches before i was
you know fairly articulate with how
we've we've worded things and
they said okay so what's this show about
and uh
knoxville points to germany and jeff
goes all right
all right all right so um
picture this it's like jackass
but they don't do drugs
okay so i'm like that's your whole bit
that is your [ __ ] no video no anything
a month later we had a show on mtv yeah
dude